الكثير من التطورات شهدها تويتر بعد نحوي
10 ايام فقط من استحواذ ايلون ماسك على
الموقع المنصه اليوم تواجه ازمه قد تصف
بخطه ملياردير طموح الازمه يمكن اختصارها
بكلمتين هروب المعلنين شركات كبرى استجابه
لضغوطات المنظمات الحقوقيه وعلقت
اعلاناتها مؤقتا على تويتر وذلك لحين
معرفه اتجاهات المنصه في ظل الاداره
الجديده ومدى تسامحها مع محتويات الكراهيه
والمعلومات المضلله او فصل الموظفين لا
يساعد ويشككه في النوايا المنصه بالفعل
تشهد تراجع عن هائلا من حيث الارادات
والمستخدمون يهددون بالتغريد في مكان اخر
وسط هذه الفوضى ماسك يسر على فرد ثمانيه
دولارات رسوم شهريه مقابل الاحتفال بعلامه
التوثيق الزرقاء ماسك يريد تقليل اعتماد
تويتر على الاعلانات والتي تمثل 90% من
الاجمالي ايرادات من الصعب لانه يحتاج الى
الوقت
[موسيقى]
هل تتوقعين ان يتراجع ماسك عن فرض رسوم
على علامه التوفيق الزرقاء
التوفيق العلامه الزرقاء كانت شائعات
وكلنا مترددين حتى انا من الاشخاص الذي
قلت لا ما اعتقد لانه لما سوى
يعني
تقريبا المليون ونصف شخص 80% من الاشخاص
قالوا انهم لم يدفعوا مقابل ذلك يعني هي
كيف او التوثيق يعني هي حريه التعبير صارت
بفلوس منهم زملاءنا كثير همم
تويتر مشاهير كبار
اليوم تويتر يحقق خمسه مليارات من العوائد
السنويه عوائد يعني مدخول وليس مو عفوا مو
دخل مو ارباح عوائد اللي هي ارادات اليوم
90% من هذه الايرادات تاتي من الاعلانات
غير اللي قلنا عن البلوس سبسكربشن اللي هو
خمس دولارات اليوم هذه الاعلانات انسحبت
لوريال انسحبت جنرال موتورز هناك شركه
اسمها انتر بابك هي احدى اكبر المجموعات
الاعلانيه هناك همم مثلا مجموعات مدنيه
تضغط على شركات مثل كوكاكولا وامازون
لازاله اعلاناتها من على تويتر بسبب
المحتوى غير اللائق الذي لا يناسب مجتمع
على تويتر فهذه كلها اليوم تتعرض للضغوط
احتماليه ان تنسحب ايضا الى الماسك برر
انه بسبب هذه المجموعات اللي تضغط على
المعلنين بسبب هذه المجموعات هو اليوم
يطرد العديد من الموظفين لانه اليوم تويتر
يخسر اربعه منذ ان استلمه ماسك الاداره
يخسر بعد ما ملايين دولار يوميا من
العوائد منذ ان استلم الى الماسك اداره
بسبب انسحاب المعلنين